you famously in this book wrote about
your first sit-down with with Donald
Trump and everybody knows that story I'd
like to know about your first sit-down
with Obama with President Barack Obama
do you remember that yeah very well it
was focused on was a conversation in the
Oval Office the theme of which was the
FBI has to be separate from the White
House and the President and I had
supported his political opponents and he
was saying I don't care
I need independence and separation which
is why I was stunned that shortly before
we walked out of the Oval Office the day
before he the day he announced my
nomination he stopped me I was there
with director Bob Muller who was leaving
that day and President Obama said a gym
before we go out I need to ask you to
honor a commitment that Bob has made to
me and I stopped and thought well what
about all that talk about separation
independence and he said bob has long
committed to allow me to use the FBI
basketball court this wave of relief
wash don't you can have any time you
wanna see yeah now Trump tomorrow is
gonna be tweeting he admitted special
Obama talk to him there was collusion
with the basketball court
you